all right so we begin with breaking news
from the United States and the former
leader of the far-right proud boys group
has been convicted of plotting to attack
the U.S capital on January the 6th 2021.
Enrico tario has been found guilty of
seditious conspiracy along with three
other members of the group The Charge
carries a possible prison term of up to
20 years prosecutors say extremist
groups were trying to forcefully stop
the lawful transition of power from
Donald Trump to Joe Biden Let's cross to
our correspondent Hydro Castro who's
live in Washington DC and Heidi tell us
more about this verdict
well Nick this was a long trial it
lasted 15 weeks and the deliberations
went off for nearly 30 hours and of
course that verdict coming in this
morning that for Enrique tario and three
other members of the far right group The
Proud boys guilty of seditious
conspiracy their sentencing will be
determined at a later date but as you
said the maximum punishment here is 20
years in prison now this charge of
seditious conspiracy it had been rarely
used in American history up until
basically now as the Fallout from the
January 6th ride at the Capitol
continues this was actually the third
trial in which a jury has found
defendants guilty of seditious
conspiracy which is a very high level
crime here in the United States now
prosecutors said that the proud boys
consider themselves to be Trump's Army
and that internal messaging between them
and also posts on social media they said
that they were wanting to keep Trump in
power by any by any means necessary
including Force as far as their leader
in mkitario was interesting because he
wasn't actually present in Washington DC
on the day of that Riot however
prosecutors made a case that convinced
jurors that tario was a big part of the
planning for the violence and that's why
he was convicted of this conspiracy
charge they pointed to his own messages
in his phone that they were just able to
crack earlier this year in which he said
make no mistake we did this in reference
to the January 6th Riot so how is the
proud boys place blame for the attack on
the U.S capital on Donald Trump
well we saw tario's own defense attorney
try to make that argument apparently
unsuccessfully to this jury but saying
that it was really Trump who was behind
this ride and that tario and the other
defendants were being scapegoated for
this effort to keep the former president
uh in office now of course we still know
that Trump is facing his own legal
investigation into his potential goal in
this matter he was impeached by Congress
ultimately acquitted of that in that
political trial but his legal troubles
when it comes to the January 6 Riot
which of course was aimed at uh
overturning the 2020 election defeat of
trump to Joe Biden we know that Trump is
still being investigated for his role in
that
Heidi thanks for that to Heidi J Castro
there in Washington DC